this is gonna be a great conversation
not only because he's just engaging he's
engaging as all get out but uh his
patriots are atop the afc east and
there's always a fun conversation when
the creator and star of netflix's f is
for family joins the show the fifth and
final season of f is for family will be
available on thanksgiving day on netflix
joining us right here is a man who's
also getting set to go on his arena and
amphitheater tour bill burr slight
return that's in parentheses here on the
mercedes-benz van phone line is bill
burr how you doing bill
what's going on rich oh i'm just excited
for you that's what i'm excited for just
you all right you know what i was
listening to that conversation about
russell wilson going yeah i always love
that whole thing you're going to get two
first-round draft picks and everybody
gets oh boy oh boy like that's a lock
if you go through all the number one
draft picks throughout history most of
them
stink
so you're going to give up a proven guy
to take a shot at these other guys and
if you've noticed bill belichick always
traded away his first round draft picks
and got more in the second round the guy
won six super bowls doing that so i
think i think number one draft picks are
overrated unless
there's you need a quarterback or some
superstar position there's a guaranteed
guy
in and even then that's usually the
first three picks but if they give you
like a 12th
a number 12
you know i mean you're talking like
that's like tony easton number no
offense well spoken like a man whose
sporting life got changed by 199th
overall draft selection that's what it
sounds like to me bill
that's what that takes yeah i mean i
kind of seen the best since paul brown
to do it and that's the way he's been
doing it so um i think that that would
be a steal for the giants if they could
only give him two first rounds well i
would be more than that that even guy
that would be open that would be the
opener that would be that would be the
start of it but i understand what that
would be the appetizer
yes it would definitely be the
mozzarella sticks of that deal there's
no question about that exactly okay or
unless i didn't realize there was an
entree
by the way in this country people got to
stop calling the first edition entree
no no no the main course in andre sorry
why is that
well entre in french means the beginning
that's true phrase the beginning yes we
screwed that up so we go what do you
want for your entree it's like i'll have
a stake
it's like yeah no
so
are you stay are you standing for the
french is that what that is for you or i
love you
have you ever been to paris they've
earned their arrogance
[Music]
all right and we always show up in our
basketball shorts going for my entree
i'll have the duck and they just look at
us like where you know
you gotta make an effort you know what i
mean just if you just make an effort
they're really cool people yeah they
just want you to actually i love the
entire mediterranean
palestinians israelis that doesn't make
sense it's like at like in alabama and
auburn but i like them both
all the way through uh spain
but i don't think francis is frank
francis i guess it's a little sliver on
the mediterranean yeah that's right look
at you bill you know you need a little
sliver it's a little triviera that's
right it's right there that way you put
your fancy teeth
during the winter time
i could see you want a yacht put the
screen on top of your head yeah drinking
the domain not whatever the heck they're
serving there
that's what i'm doing that's it bill
burr here hey you earned it thank you
bill like the
french these white chicks i've heard all
these white chicks
they're all living their best life
you don't believe it you can read their
yoga pants it says it right on the side
ladies and gentlemen bill burr here on
the rich eisen show okay so
um uh what do you think of your patriots
bill what do you think i am ridiculous
this uh this is feeling very
it's beginning to look a lot like 2001.
sorry it's the holidays i like the
holidays i like it too yes
we where we got this you know starting
to look like really good defense and
then we got this rookie quarterback like
who is this guy this guy's doing
he's not messing up but there's nothing
there he doesn't take a sack he throws
it out of bounds he keeps getting better
week after week and uh the only thing
that scares me is kind of what you knew
was going to happen at some point kc was
going to right the ship everybody was
just saying they were a bad football
team
and all of a sudden it's not a it's not
a good looking record but they are in
first place
and they've been to the last two super
bowls in the afc so the big thing for me
is what
explain to me what is happening in
buffalo because i was taking them every
week double-digit favorites and they
were covering
and then they just started to nosedive
they lose to jacksonville
and then carson wentz lights them up in
their own building all right that's a
great question going on in buffalo
that's a great question i do not know um
and they appear to be ready to be uh
plucked to use the i guess the phrase of
the holiday and um and and here come the
patriots
just in time like you know the time they
get new england was first six weeks of
the season that's when you wanted them
right now i don't think anybody wants a
piece of them i do not know we're going
to see them on thanksgiving night
against the saints they should win that
game as that's the uh that's the sort of
a hedging way that we talk in in the nfl
media world as they should uh thus i
can't be helping responsible
jameis winston's out right pretty much
trevor simeon's not scaring the bills
i'll tell you that you know and so um
i'll tell you he scares me
well you know here's
here's the deal here here's the deal
you're you're right they do look like
2001 and where where the entire year is
like yeah but well i guess i guess you
know bledsoe will come back eventually
there is no blood cell in the equation
that's the only part of this that does
not appear to be
a mirror of 2001 where everybody thinks
it's not going to happen and then all of
a sudden you're you're you're you're
picking confetti out of your hair you
know and yeah and all the all the espn
guys used to say back then they said we
were a boring team
and and we won three of the last four
super bowls and somehow we were like
this boring team right and uh tell you
if you gotta pick a guy you gotta go
with peyton manning that's what they
kept saying but you know that all that
used to bug me you know i haven't said
that though bill i've been i've been on
the patriots for quite some time this
year
i've been honored to flipping like a
politician
i bet i can go back to 2001 when we both
had a hairline i bet you said something
well
no i was sitting there on the set of
sports center talking about the michigan
man you know i have that sort of soft
spot you know i'm not that right there
but you know i was talking about the way
yeah are you are you bracing yourself
for this game this weekend i mean i feel
like the the
the destruction of michigan by ohio
state started last weekend against
michigan state
it's just the big ten it's you know what
is
annoying me the hell out of ohio state
they haven't played anybody
it's not their fault the big ten stinks
but the only team that they've played is
oregon and they got their bus kick and
they're still they're they're in the
playoff every year
there's no consequences for their
actions
so walk me through because you are a
michigan fan bill i know that yeah this
is completely unbiased opinion of course
so so you're a michigan fan walk me
through where where are you watching the
game saturday what is your what are you
going to do because i'm basically
locking myself in a room on saturday
what's up
what's your way of going about well you
know what i usually do is i you know i
have a bunch of michigan fans out here
but you know with all the cobin stuff i
don't know what i'm gonna do uh
i usually try to well i got two kids you
know four and under so i try to watch as
much of the game as i can
before they say to put on you know
sophie or uh
was it bluey
as long as it isn't that one with that
stupid little i don't know what it is
the dog
which dog the puppy dog pals you got a
problem with the puppy no no no i love
puppy dog pills there's one
it's like a guy a high-energy guy
and he's saying stuff and then there's
like this dog that's get no matter what
he says
he has to react to everything it's like
he ever just like nod your head
he comments on everything that guy's
saying and after a while it just it
makes mike are you referring to blues
clues
yes
yes
i thank god that's been out of my wife
my life for a long time as his caillou
which is the most miserable occur on the
planet that canada has ever ever foisted
on the rest of the world that i believe
that uh the worst i wouldn't want to
talk to somebody named kair oh
caillou caillou by the way you just
avoid him like the plague sir uh that
sounds like one of those new names you
know all of all of our names are going
away
bill rich mike steve gone
that's like two generations ago like
hunter i think is an old name at this
point
oh
my gosh all right so you're going to be
locking yourself in a room trying to
avoid uh blues clues oh my god that's
what i'm going to do i got a great cigar
okay and and i got myself some root beer
because i can't drink anymore because uh
you know i just did it too much oh the
last time i ever drank
was three years ago watching the
michigan ohio state game i remember i
was drinking this this rye that was
amazing kentucky owl i looked at my
buddy and i said i'm never quitting
because it was that delicious and then
the next day i woke up i was like i
should take a break from this
usually michigan ohio state rivalry for
michigan fans drives you to drink and
drove you to sobriety huh you went the
other direction
i had a weird yeah i got a weird thing
like that like i i have uh i just
i don't know i just wake up i look at my
actions and i'm like you know maybe i
should stop doing that for a minute and
i tried to go to like new year's then i
tried to go to my birthday then i tried
to go birthday to birthday
and then it was it was so hard to quit i
was like i don't have to quit again so i
just sort of stopped all right i'll wait
till my kids are out of the house and
then i'm coming back strong remember
when jim brown came back on the raiders
that's gonna be me drinking that's it
bill burr here on the rich eisen show uh
f is for family fifth and final season
just in time for thanksgiving day
on netflix fun stuff brother um so yeah
and then that whole series is wrapped
and i want to thank the great mike price
from the simpsons for being the captain
of the ship all these years everybody at
beaumont netflix all the voice over
actors all the writers everybody editors
i learned so much doing the show and uh
we all had a blast and thank you of
course first and foremost to the fans
who watched it people love it brother um
patty lupone and neil patrick harris
joining the cast this season who do they
play
this year
i i would tell you but that i can't like
okay just like the mandalorian but the
cartoon version okay well i was gonna
ask you about the mandalorian are you
coming back or what come on now come on
uh
i'm not allowed to say any of that stuff
come on bill they left us they left me
in the woods on some planet far far away
oh no no can you figure out a way to
bring me back of course i can
they could do anything and i i i would i
would say who they brought back at the
end of season one but i it's still it's
a spoiler alert i don't even want to go
there you know what i mean like they can
bring anybody back they can bring you
back i like watching sports
there's no spoiler alert after you got
like 24 hours to watch the game although
larry david was on the show bill larry
david was on this show last month and he
said
that his
he gets upset when somebody sends a text
about a game about that's happening that
day
and he said you should always assume
tape even for live sports i told him no
i agree with that i agree with that on
the day of but the next day that's on
you
what about you
you just and you don't even say
you don't even allude to what's going on
you just say
are you going to watch the game today
that's it you got to say this you don't
even say are you watching this yeah but
if michigan
if michigan does well saturday of course
i'm gonna text you uh what am i supposed
to think you're on tape really during
the michigan ohio state game should i
should i assume
the exception is a game that big okay so
like
you know what i mean i mean it's like a
regular c you know you know especially
like that the teams where they got like
uh they got like 80 games or 162 games
in a regular season those are the ones
you kind of tape
and you know everybody gets to bed or
whatever and then you're downstairs
you know in your pajamas and you you put
it on you know all right and then your
buddy texts you just going like big win
for the socks huh am i right
yeah but there's a thing i'll still
watch the game i don't care because
you're like oh good this i like i like a
game with a happy ending you die hard
man okay and then bill burr presents
immoral compass that is on uh on the
roku channel a dark psychological
thriller comedy series is what it says
down here yes and it's actually i'm
getting way too much credit on that
thing you know i'm the beautiful face of
it that's why i keep getting the credit
there well you're you're on the
mandalorian bill you know what i'm
saying
of course
is tyler falbo and that's a name
remember that name okay all of those you
got to watch that show those those dark
little movies that he that he
writes and everything him and his
friends are absolutely hilarious the way
he shot him is amazing you gotta see
vince vaughn and bobby lee on screen
together fantastic um uh
mary lynn rice cub uh al madrigal
there's so many great people on that
show and but the writing and the
directing by tyler falbel uh the creator
of the show i can't even begin to tell
you how amazing it was to work with this
kid he's gonna do awesome amazing things
in this business okay um and then your
arena and amp amphitheater across north
america throughout 2022 and people can
get tickets that's right through where
on you got a website for that sort of
thing bill or what do we got for me on
getting tickets uh yeah i think it's uh
you know ticket tron live nation
whatever i mean i put them on my website
because they always push my they always
push my website down
so i know my role in the business it's
funny i'm playing with the canadians
play
so you had yeah the the pre-sale
password was dope bruins
come on
you know what i should have made it
marshawn because then then i probably
wouldn't have sold any tickets i
couldn't go that far
i just had to say go bro oh that is
funny man that is funny all right all
right um so uh do do we screw it
do we see you in better call saul do you
come back for that too bill come on
listen these you're not allowed to say
any of these things okay but you're
bringing up some of the best shows
on tv so i mean the chances are you know
you know they got a lot of talent over
there okay so you know
so that's a yes okay um same for the
mandalorian right that's yes too bill
come on come on you're fine in the
business they're not gonna blackball you
because you're saying yeah i'm in the
mandalorian they absolutely will you're
not disposable i am just think of how
many good looking guys with abs did
something stupid and they're not even
there i'm a bald orange man
[Laughter]
oh
what do they got against bald orange men
in the business who talk about their
projects that are popular type but it's
never been brought up
i know all these fat women can get they
can complain but i can't complain
all right bill burr have a great
thanksgiving i'm gonna text you on
saturday feminists act like it's a man
you could be like completely out of
shape and be a movie star it's like no
you're either the fat guy or you're in
shape every agent has always told me
that like what are you doing buddy
you're going to be 300 pounds you're
going to be in shape
but you're you're you're doing great
bill you're killing it right now you're
killing it i mean you're at some of the
best stuff of all time and you're going
to be in the mandalorian again and we'll
look forward to seeing your better call
song
all right and you're going to be in the
huddle for the los angeles ramp
who knows they're getting everybody
they're getting everybody so i look
forward to it that would be the lakers
uh-huh the lakers look like the cast of
uh
uh what the heck what are those stallone
movies there
oh the the expendables these are the
spendables
yeah
they're doing the expendable version of
of uh in the nba team
the expendables that's fantastic we got
to make that we got somebody's got to
make that uh that mock movie poster for
that
all right bill you take care of yourself
have a great thanksgiving all right rich
you take care of yourself thank you bill
i appreciate that i care about you i
care about you bill burr everybody right
here on the rich eisen show at bill burr
on twitter wilfred burr on instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here